hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer
and today we are going to be talking
about the fastest
quickest easiest way to become a
software engineer
in 2021 now i'm
sure if any of y'all have looked outside
some
ish went down between january 2020
to march 2020 because of this and
because of
this sudden influx of jobs and companies
moving to online a lot of demand has
shown up
for software engineers and web
developers to be
able to assist in the migration of
companies from
in person to online and not even in the
migration but also
being able to build upon the current
systems in place because
now it's one thing having let's say 10
people you know using
your platform but now having a thousand
people using your platform because
they have no other choice now when we
think about even smaller mom and pop
shops let's say
food trucks and coffee shops and things
like that
all of these different places have now
needed to find
a way to gain an online presence gain in
online branding
in order to sustain their business
because again
we're all up in this house it's now
companies large and small
needing to find a way to sustain their
online
presence and being now much more willing
to hire web developers
than they may have been in the past
because maybe they thought it was
unnecessary and all that so let's get
into it so the first thing you want to
do to become a software engineer
in the quickest time possible is learn
the bare
bones of the structure you will
be building and what is that that
is html and css
html standing for a hypertext markup
language
css standing for cascading style sheets
these two things come together to create
really
a basic site with html being really the
text that you see on the site so when
you see
a header on the site when you see a
title when you see
paragraphs or quotes or links that's
html now when you see that
the page isn't just a white page
background
with this black text on top of it as a
title as paragraph as links
that is because they're using css
css is responsible for the styling of
things
and to be honest people like to sleep on
css people like to very quickly just
breathe by it
thinking that it's not going to make a
difference or it's not as important
as you know javascript and ruby and
react and all of this stuff
but y'all it really is because you know
what
when you submit your portfolio for a
company when you
are now building that app building that
website what's going to make it look
pretty
css y'all when was the last time you
went to a site and you decided to like
oh no i'm getting
out of here because it looked all kinds
of messed up yeah
that's css y'all so you want to make
sure
you really put in the practice with that
to really make sure that at the end of
it all what you have
spent so much time building looks nice
and pretty and sleek and clean and
all of these things that make audiences
and consumers and customers gravitate
to that site to that app to that
business so do not sleep on that y'all
like seriously spend
hours days weeks really honing in on css
because that's another thing it is so
hard to
pick on on css than the other languages
and frameworks because the other
languages and frameworks have like
a clear right and wrong css y'all yo
once you do one thing you think you're
changing the background color but then
you're changing
just this little box in the corner and
then you think you're changing the font
size only to this
and it goes haywire so being able to
really hone down and continue practicing
css is so
so necessary when it comes to html html
y'all is quite straightforward it is
quite straightforward it took me
a night if that
to really learn html because it comes
with its own
very clear set of rules if you want a
title
make sure it's marked with this if you
want a paragraph make sure it's marked
with this
and there you go go on your way and work
good
and also it's very googleable and so you
can definitely get away with
knowing less html because if you need to
you know create a
chart in within your site now you can
just google how to create a chart in
html and boom
there it is but first step you need to
know
the bones of this structure bones of
this house
you need to be able to build
a real nice structure and that
is with html and css so
now you know html and css and so now
you can create static websites for
people for friends family when i say
static website that is typically
just a landing page you go
google i don't even know pets.com
and you just see a website with just a
bunch of pets pictures
some names of the pets and all of this
and that's it there's no
you know adoption type service there's
no
you know buying things for your pet at
home or anything
there's no service being produced or
accessed or anything like that it is
what you see is what you get you go on
go off and so now
you are able to build a static site and
so if you can
take about a day or two after practicing
html and css css in particular
start building some static sites think
about your hobbies think about
things that interest you and create a
site for it just you know
one page try to make it have a banner
try to make it have different
images and you know different borders
and things like that and just try to
make it as pretty as possible
and if you can do that you're in a very
very good spot
so just get that practice in don't just
rush and learn
and then go on your day you need to make
sure you get your practice in with
actual projects because that is how you
test your abilities
and that's how you will be able to
become a software engineer in the
quickest time possible so
the next thing you need to do this is i
want to say yes this is number three
you want to learn javascript so
so when it comes to web development the
three things you
will really really hear most talked
about are html
css and javascript now i like to use
this you know
other you know simile of
you know what where html is the
person you're dating css
is the way they look and javascript is
the way
they act the way they treat you put all
these things together and you
have your perfect or not so perfect
person so these three things together
you have really a lot under your belt as
to
web development especially front end
software engineering front end web
development because now you're able to
create the content of a site
you're also able with css to style it
and with javascript
that's what creates the actions and so
being able to say
when i click here it's going to do this
and when i
swipe here it's going to go here and
this is going to change this is going to
change
javascript is how things change within
the app you are creating
so it is very very important and it is
what differentiates
between just a site and an app an
app it has functionalities it has
resources it has
services it can provide it has you know
actions
a site is just chilling there just you
know there it is you what you see like i
said is what you get
but then adding that action adding that
functionality
that is when you can now actually do
something with your app whether it be an
e-commerce site whether it be
a social app all this stuff that is
where that magic happens so four
the next thing you need to do to become
a software engineer in the quickest this
rapid-fire possible
is learn a back end technology
so you just heard me talk about front
end just now
so front end and back end these two
things together is what creates
an app and so front end is what you see
it's what you can actually trace
and being able to say okay this did this
and when i clicked here it did this and
these colors are this and this these
words are here
that's front end that is what the user
actually interacts with
back end it allows for content to be
fed to the front end and so back and
when you hear front-end and back-end
engineers
one way back-end works is to provide
basically
storage for data and so if you want
your app or site to be able to say
when i click here i want to be able to
see
all of the cities with the name that
starts with the name b
and so all you have to do is click the
button b cities and
there it pops up well it pops up because
of what was stored
in the back end so these two things
communicate to each other
to ultimately provide a service or a
result
to the user and so i highly recommend
learning ruby as your first
back-end technology ruby is extremely
extremely
easy to read it was made with the
thought of simplicity while also being
highly productive specifically when
joined
with ruby on rails what's ruby on rails
ruby on rails is a library or a
framework
built upon ruby to really allow
developers to build
apps in the easiest way possible being
able to
provide ideally everything the developer
would need
to provide the app with everything they
want
really like ruby on rails it's extremely
daunting
at first if you just look up ruby on
rails and you see all the files
and all the folders and files within
folders and folders and files
it is can be so so daunting to look at
but when you start seeing how things
connect
and why this folder exists and this file
exists and where
what goes where it becomes so much more
manageable and becomes such a smaller
world and less of this big daunting
place
so i highly recommend learning ruby and
then ruby on rails
learn will be first y'all like you're
not going to be a successful software
engineer by skipping steps
so it's very important to learn
the basics or the
the vanilla okay you know it's like this
y'all learned long division before
being handed a calculator correct it's
the exact same thing here
because now even though you have the
calculator you
know what the calculator is doing you
know what
the process of dividing is
if you just start with ruby on rails
it'll be i'd say
very difficult in the future for you
now maybe you are able to make an app
but you don't really understand how
you understand how to you you were able
to do it because you followed a tutorial
or
you followed some you know udemy course
or this that
or the other but you don't really know
why it worked and it's so important to
know why it worked because
when you become an engineer your boss
says hey do this this is
this you need to know why things work
to know the best approach to solve a
certain problem you need to know
how things connect with each other how
things go from here to here
for you to be able to go into a certain
program go into
a certain project and fulfill that task
for your boss so please start with ruby
first just
ruby itself the language before going on
to that
udemy course and following along this
ruby on rails tutorial and
i say that because y'all the amount of
udemy courses
i bought i want to say i bought six of
them and sure i was able to build things
and it was cool once i did but yeah i
didn't know the
biggest clue about why this worked and
if you asked me to do it by myself i may
have been able to do it because i
memorized the steps but i don't know
why i did those tips because i wasn't
learning for myself
i was just following along and so please
learn ruby first
learn how the language is structured
again it's very very easy very very
readable
and then go on to ruby on rails
so now with these things html and css
javascript and ruby on rails you now
have
every single thing you need
to create a full stack
web application this is
major this is truly truly major because
you can now actually with just these
things
create an actual like social media app
you do
now it's a matter of how do we
translate these quon quote more
basic skills into hireable skills
one way and one very important way is to
now learn
front-end frameworks so ruby on rails
was a back-end framework
now let's learn front-end frameworks
because while
javascript is very very important for
the front-end
people aren't using javascript so now
when i say javascript i mean vanilla
javascript
which is the term of you know the long
division
type of javascript people aren't using
long
as i say people aren't using long
division they're not
but people aren't using
vanilla javascript to create their apps
they're not
because we have front-end frameworks to
allow us
to do things quicker and provide us with
the necessary tools and functionalities
to create these nice big sleek
functional apps
in a much less time and so learn
a front-end framework i highly recommend
react or angular or view these are
all frameworks based on javascript and
so now you've learned javascript so now
let's make sure
that your frameworks very much you know
correlate with javascript so because
again we're trying to do this
we're we're not wasting any time like we
got to be quick here we're trying to get
that bag as we're in a panoramic like we
need money
now and so these three frameworks
are very very highly utilized within
companies within startups within
large tech firms they are very very
highly utilized
and so you want to be able to build with
these frameworks
to now be able to put on your resume
like look i do you use react
great so do i so you want to be able to
say that
and again don't be daunted when i say
things like frameworks and you know
dictionaries and libraries and
functionalities like
all that all i'm saying is get a
calculator in your hand
and now just learn how to use it and
it's going to take you know a little bit
of time to use this calculator
but now everything you do is going to be
so much
faster so much high-tech and so much
more transferable to
other companies when you're trying to
get a job so please like
i know it's a lot of just spillage
on all you but please breathe
that's all i'm just saying grab a
calculator now that you have learned
html and css javascript
a back-end technology hopefully ruby
and ruby on rails and now you have
learned
a front-end framework let's say react
and you know view or view or angular
now go to your friends
go to your family try to find someone
with
a very like a hobby they're very much
into
or a business that they just started or
you know they've been doing for a while
try to find a friend or family member
who has either a business of their own
or a hobby that can very much be shown
online a hobby let's say your friend
is um an artist and so go to them and
say
hey i noticed you know you're a
very talented artist and i bet you've
thought about selling your products
let me create a site for you let me
create a web app for you
an app in general let me create
something for you
and i want you to be able to use it this
is a great way to get your practice in
one and
also add things to your resume because
now what's going to happen get a pen and
paper because i'm very serious about
this
you go to your friend ask them to build
a site or an
app for them they say yes now
you too need to sit down and you need to
hear and take notes on every single
thing
that they want their site or app to
encompass
what color schemes do they want what
kind of field do they want do
they want it to be sleek and clean and
uncluttered or do they want it to be
like
really in your face really busy and you
know
fun and you know all of this what vibe
are they looking for
what's their target customer their
target market because that also affects
you know
color schemes and fonts and all of this
and everything
then ask for deadlines then
when you go back to you know your own
house your own office your own bedroom
draw some markups for them and go back
to them and say
here after these conversations we had
i drew up three to four designs for
how your app will look like which one do
you like more
these designs will have let's say like
the layout with you know if we want a
navigation up here and then we want you
know the columns down here and then
a chart here and things like that just
draw four different iterations of that
then when they pick one go back and
start
building the app for them keep them
updated
and make sure you are following the
deadlines that they set
this is amazing practice
for when you get a job because that is
what a job is
a company expects you to be able to take
their vision
and produce it they want somebody who
can take
an idea and turn it into something real
something real something
tangible something they can actually see
and so by
doing this and practicing this with your
friends and family people who will not
you know fire you
or you know maybe fire you but still
keep you on as a friend slash you know
daughter or son like now you are able to
get
practice in not only developing but also
get practice
and following
i want to say direction but i don't want
it to sound as if it's like
like falling orders more of a thing of
like
being able to take someone's vision and
put it
to actuality because
it's very that's something that's very
difficult because
we are people who have our own styles
our own way of doing things and so being
able to actually take some
something that somebody wants despite
our own opinions or views or anything
and still produce something that both of
us are proud of
that takes tremendous patience and skill
and discipline
and so you want to practice this as much
as possible
and if they end up using what you
created for them
if your friend if your mother if your
brother end up using this or even better
yet paying you for it
now you can put it on your resume as
experience because
you know what you were just a freelance
developer
for them and for their company and for
their business
which is he huge and companies don't
take that
lightly it is so so important i got
hired just off
projects i didn't even have you know
experience to say oh no a company hired
me
to do this and i did it so now imagine
if you can put that on your resume and
talk about it during your interviews
that will be
huge so there you have everybody the
quickest way to become a software
engineer in 2021
do these things and really really devote
time to it and you can become a software
engineer
in six months or less and it takes
discipline
it does it takes being able to draw
boundaries with your family and friends
and you know
being able to have actual like working
hours dedicated to your school
dedicated to your self-teaching journey
and really really come out of this the
other side
with something you're proud of a job
your own
business your own company anything like
that so it takes discipline
but if you do have that discipline you
can do this
by by the summer y'all you can be a
software engineer
so thank you so much for watching please
subscribe below
and like and comment and let me know
what other videos you'd like
to see from me but for now i'll see
y'all
later bye